Food for type pills three times a day.
All your nutrients,
all your favorite flavors,
feel like having lobster for breakfast
done trying to like mushrooms,
but you can't stand the texture.
Problem solved.
Meal replacement pills are the future.
At least that's what people have
been saying for the past century.
So what if we got them now? How would they
affect our diet? Would we be healthier?
Could they solve world hunger?
Will we see them in our lifetime?
This is what if,
and here's what would happen if
you could get your meals in a pill.
Mill pills began as a feminist
ideal leading up to the
1893 Chicago world's fair.
The American Press Association asked
writers to predict the world of 1993 so
American suffragette Mary Elizabeth lease
described a world of synthetic food,
freeing women from kitchen work and
other domestic chores in the decades that
followed science fiction,
novelists, playwrights, filmmakers,
and others from different disciplines
all experimented with the idea of meal
replacement pills. The best we've
come up with so far is soylent.
Soylent is a thick and creamy concoction
that contains all the fat, carbs,
proteins, vitamins, and minerals you need
in a day. So if we can drink our meals,
why can't we pop them?
It wouldn't be hard to replace a portion
of your diet with nutrient pills.
After all,
you can pick up every essential vitamin
in pill form at your local grocery store
or pharmacy.
In doing so,
you might think you're pretty
nutritious and intelligent,
but you wouldn't look at, you'd
grow irritable, depressed, tired,
and you'd eventually die of starvation
because it's not just nutrients we need
to survive.
Calories are crucial.
The average adult needs 2000
calories per day to survive.
What does that look like? Here's the
breakdown for breakfast. Eat two eggs,
a slice of bread,
two tablespoons of peanut butter,
and a glass of juice for lunch. How
about a Turkey Sandwich? Carrots and dip,
a chocolate chip cookie and a
glass of milk. And then for dinner,
you could grow up some salmon, add a
baked potato, some steamed Broccoli,
and a cup of ice cream for dessert.
And if you need a snack during the day,
grab an apple and a Granola bar
and you've hit 2000 calories.
So how do you fit all that into
one pill? You don't. You can't.
Even if fat is the most
concentrated source of calories,
you can't fit enough of
it into a single pill.
But if you were set on
subsisting on a pill only diet,
then you'd have to eat 450 calorie pills
a day plus other vitamins to get your
needed nutrients.
That's sort of how soylent was invented.
Living in San Francisco with high
rent and a high grocery bill.
Rob Rhinehart thought to
economize through chemistry.
He found out what the
body needed to survive,
ordered the raw ingredients mostly in
powdered form, tossed them in a blender,
added water and mixed up
a healthy hardy cocktail.
Reinhardt's grocery bill went from
$470 a month down to $50 with a meal
replacement pill.
We could imagine a much more efficient
world and one with greater food security
since future meals would be easier and
cheaper to manufacture and send around
the world.
The effects of climate change today
are beginning to limit what we can grow
mangoes and Avocados, for example, are
among the fruits that are in decline.
While farms around the world are seeing
fewer yields due to global warming and
increased drought, we may never get
it in one pill, but it's possible,
if not likely, that full meal
replacements are the way of the future.
And if you're afraid that all your
favorite flavors would disappear,
if all your food came in a pill,
don't be.
Researchers at the Institute of Food
Research and Nora England recently found a
way to put multiple flavors into a single
capsule and have them released one at
a time at different intervals. So
what's the future of food? Fast,
frugal and flavorful won't have fatigue.